[Musique]
dis moi qui tu te seras seul au milieu
de la tour quand plus rien osé toucher
ton coeur dis le moi que ce soit fait
trop mal on a tellement bien que j'étais
évidemment mal c'est normal vous avez
déjà sûrement quelqu'un vous vous voulez
sauver quelqu'un barrez-vous délicieux à
l'aide ses stars à domicile
oui alors bye bye c'est bien au nom mais
celui un producteur oui toi aussi tu vas
faire quoi niqueurs à domicile bien
est-ce que vous avez déjà envoyé un
texto à une femme pendant que vous étiez
en couple avec une autre femme voilà
c'est ça la question
non monsieur
j'adore le monde
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
jean zay êtes avez vous déjà payé pour
du sexe c'est vrai jamais jamais une
fois non c'est la seule réponse
[Musique]
on va donner la parole à kaka qui va
calmer les esprits et il va dire quelque
chose dont on se fout certainement
fabien je suis moche ouais mais je m'en
bats les couilles
[Musique]
plus visuelle que les dix commandements
voici votre comédie musicale cyril c'est
parti
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
sans bagages
oubliée sur l'image
on était d'accord il indiqué c'est
vraiment une très grosse
[Applaudissements]
il est le grand maître d'arts martiaux
de la télévision française et il est de
retour
faux
[Musique]